I was an entrepreneur my whole life I
was a very bad student I couldn't
concentrate on things that I didn't
think were important and for me I was
always very self-aware that I was a good
salesman and I loved the action of
selling stuff I I grew up in my dad's
liquor store that he eventually owned in
New Jersey and I got involved full time
when I was 22 years old after university
and I grew my dad's business from a
three to a sixty million dollar business
in a five-year window I want to take a
step back I want everybody understand
that the skill set that allowed me to
build that business from 3 to 60 million
in a short period of time the skill set
that allowed me to be an early investor
in Twitter and Tumblr and and an early
investor in uber and all the things that
are gonna make me extremely wealthy are
interesting to me because when I think
of myself as a businessman as a marketer
as an individual I think that I stink at
most thinks I really struggle with most
things I for the same reason I was a DNF
student there's a lot of things I can't
do but the one thing I can do and the
one thing that I would challenge this
room to find out if they have that
within themselves or to surround
themselves with that kind of individual
the one thing I'm great at is I know
what you're gonna do before you're gonna
do it and so my entire career all I've
ever spent my time on is where is the
arbitrage where all of you think you
should be spending your time and money
on telling your story and where's the
grass greener because you just haven't
figured it out the reason I invested in
Twitter in 2007 was because I believed
to that be a place where that was
happening the real reason I was able to
build my wine business in such a quick
fashion was because there's something
called Google AdWords that came around
in 1999 and while all my competitors
thought that they had my ads in the Wall
Street Journal and The New York Times I
owned the word wine on Google for five
cents for nine months before anybody bid
me up then I did banner retargeting
and cookie people when people still
thought cookies was something you ate
with milk right then my career took a
very different turn because four months
after YouTube came out I started a wine
show on YouTube and I decided to educate
the masses about wine not sell them the
wine just review the wine and I would
even pan the wines that I was selling
because I knew that the age of content
was upon us and that I needed to be a
Content producer not just a commerce
executor we are living through the
single biggest culture shift in
attention since the printing press we
are living through a second Industrial
Revolution right in front of our eyes
right now I mean how many people in this
room are lucky enough to have a 12 to 20
year old in their lives child or
grandchild please raise your hands don't
get lazy on me thank you so all of you
know that that individual lives here
lives here I mean if you could if they
could they would do this and that was it
let's just forget robots we're robots I
promise you forget buying a robot that
serves you foods we're robots this how
many people in this room in every
24-hour window including when you're
sleeping are always within arm's reach
of their telephone raise your hand hold
on please keep that up I just want
people in the front because I don't
think you get to see what I'm getting to
see look around a little bit real quick
oh I don't know everybody and just to
remind everybody in this crowd as I look
around this is not a high-school-aged
crowd so what's happening what's
happening is we're not understanding we
as business people let me remind you I
love social media because it sells stuff
I don't think it's cool
I don't like technology I want to sell
something I'm a business man I'm only
doing this because you're at
chin is there you think as a business
person that the behavior is the youth
and not your actual customer I know that
it's actually you I know that we're
living through the youth of vacation of
our society that if you think about
yourself right now and you think about
your parent at your age right now if
you're lucky enough to have been around
and have a parent that was your age that
you are right now when you were a kid
and you think about them
you're acting much younger than the way
they acted at your same age we're living
through a massive youth of vacation if
you look at Instagram how many people
here by show of hands are on Instagram
raise your hand
solid number very good let's clap it up
I'm very happy with that that's for me
good job
I'm impressed if you look at Instagram
how many people here by show of hands
are familiar with selfies everyone know
that a selfie is great the fastest
growing demo on selfies on Instagram are
42 to 45 year old females that's right
cougar selfies in the last five years
our attention has shifted so much to
here and so much away from everywhere
else where they're trying to sell you
beer in cars how many people here when
you watch television
fast forward every single commercial
raise your hand everybody everybody yet
bill when he's up here to CEO of sa P
yet Honda yet every brand I work with
spends tens of billions of dollars to
tell you a story in a place where you
will use technology to get away and you
will never pay attention and even if
they're lucky enough because you dropped
your remote control off your bed and you
have to see a commercial even if they're
lucky the second that commercial comes
you're grabbing your phone and you're
tweeting checking your email and you're
not giving your attention my friends
this is with all due respect 99.9% of
the people in this room are trying to
sell their stuff in places where they're
overpaying on effort and money to get
somebody's attention period and
that is why all my friends that spend
their time doing snapchat and Instagram
and Facebook and there's other things
but that's why Hoover spends their
marketing dollars in those places and
they become multi-billion dollar
companies and that's why my clients who
spend it on print because you're gonna
go to page 167 in vogue and be like ooh
I want that which is insanity doesn't
exist that's why they're like why are we
struggling because you're an idiot